If you're a bit quiz savvy, probably this one was very easy to get,
but I'll explain the answer to you of course as well.
So, at least one variable must be flipped and the chances of flipping the right variable
are at least one-third and I''ll explain it to you.
Now, let's say we have one clause and that clause has 3 variables and it's not satisfied.
So, if the overall Boolean formula has a satisfying assignment
this means that in the satisfying assignment either this variable here, this one here, or this one here
must evaluate to true and currently, they all evaluate to false.
So, at least one of those variables must be flipped in order to satisfy the clause.
What are the chances that we're flipping the correct variable?
Meaning that we indeed choose the variable to flip
that would also have a different value in the satisfying assignment.
Well, since we select one out of three variables those chances are at least one-third.
So, they are exactly one-third.
If in a satisfying assignment, you have exactly one variable that evaluates to true
or a variable set to false with a knot and the chances are even better
if in the satisfying assignment you would have two of three variables
that would need to evaluate to true, but there are always at least one-third.
We initially can expect to get about half of the variables right
and a random change will be successful or a random change and clause that is not satisfied
will be successful with the probability of at least one-third
and that of course also means that the probability of making a mistake
meaning that we flip a variable that we should actually not have flipped
is at most two-thirds.